people told to isolate by the contact
tracing app for england and wales
are not able to claim government
financial support
how so our technology correspondent
ronald manthorp has
an exclusive story for us hello to you
roland tell us more
morning k yeah so um at the end of
september
the government brought in financial
support for low-paid workers
who were asked to self-isolate because
of risk of coronavirus
you can get 500 pound payment it's it's
very important for people
on low incomes but i found out
that if you're told by the contact
tracing app to self-isolate
you cannot claim that payment i was just
looking at the guidance reminding myself
earlier right there
it doesn't say that anywhere in the
guidance but it's true
you cannot get this payment
and this is being going to be a real
issue for people to put this in context
boris johnson has said that the most
effective way to beat the virus
is for people to self-isolate we know
that only around
20 of people are actually self-isolating
when they're told to
and that one of the key reasons is
financial worries
but all these people these 18 million
people who've downloaded the app
if they get told self-isolate they
cannot claim that
that benefits i'm told that the
department of health and social care has
known about this for at least
two weeks but hasn't put anything into
action
and i know you asked the minister about
it earlier it seemed to be news to him
but it's not news to lots of people out
there one mp told me that her
constituency her local public health
team and constituency was
inundated with requests about this and
that it was
quote causing chaos